bienvenidos a la clase de cómo completar
un cuadrado perfecto a lo que me refiero
es encontrar un método para resolver
ecuaciones de segundo grado y es justo
lo que voy a ver en este vídeo al final
ya sabemos que si tenemos una ecuación
de segundo grado podemos factorizar la
podemos utilizar la fórmula general de
segundo grado que por cierto la fórmula
general de segundo grado está demostrada
con esto de completar el cuadrado así
que vamos a verlo mejor con un ejemplo
tengo x cuadrada más 16 x menos 57
igual a cero y yo lo que quiero hacer es
completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto
de esta ecuación como se hace bueno para
esto antes de irme a resolver esta
ecuación quiero fijarme y recordar qué
pasaba cuando teníamos un binomio al
cuadrado es decir la fórmula que ya has
visto varias veces
en las clases de álgebra cuando tenemos
un binomio al cuadrado perfecto nos
queda el cuadrado del primero más dos
veces del primero por el segundo más el
cuadrado del segundo así que déjame
escribirlo por aquí para que no se nos
olvide porque esto nos va a ser muy útil
y bueno seguramente me vas a estar
diciendo oye sal pero nosotros podemos
resolver esta ecuación con fórmula
general y ya acabamos sin embargo
recuerda que siempre es bueno tener
nuevos métodos alternativos para poder
resolver los problemas de matemáticas
entre más opciones tengas para resolver
un problema de matemáticas más
herramientas vas a tener en un futuro
para poder trabajar siempre que tengas
un problema con matemáticas así que
déjame escribirlo por aquí y bueno
recordemos que es lo que pasaba cuando
teníamos algo de este estilo x menos a
elevado al cuadrado bueno es un binomio
elevado al cuadrado y por lo tanto
nuestra fórmula decía que era x cuadrada
más dos veces el primero por el segundo
2x aquí me falta la equis más el
cuadrado del segundo equis cuadrada más
2x más cuadrada y bueno la idea que hay
detrás de este ejercicio que vamos a
resolver justo ahorita es este binomio
al cuadrado que tengo aquí abajo y
aunque tal vez no aparezca acá arriba
que tenemos un binomio cuadrado perfecto
si hacemos un poco de manipulación
algebraica y utilizamos un poco nuestro
ingenio vas a darte cuenta que si en
efecto tenemos un mismo cuadrado
perfecto escondido por ahí así que no
pierdas de vista esta fórmula porque le
vamos a utilizar bastante aquí arriba y
bueno aquí tenemos x cuadrada más 16 x
menos 57 igual a 0 y seguramente me vas
a decir que 57 de hecho no es la raíz
cuadrada de ningún número natural
inclusive no es la raíz cuadrada de
ningún número real pero qué te parece si
para empezar vamos a deshacernos de ese
57 desde el lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y lo voy a pasar del otro lado
de la ecuación con signo contrario o
dicho otra manera lo que voy a hacer es
a toda esta expresión completa le voy a
sumar 57 de ambos lados de la ecuación y
entonces que me quedaría
para que no hagamos todo el tiempo
mental vamos a escribirlo
si yo paso 57 del otro lado me va a
quedar algo así como haber decido
cambiar de color x cuadrado + 16 x
aquí voy a dejar un pequeño espacio ya
verás porque el 57 se va para el otro
lado con signo positivo entonces me
queda que esto es igual a 57 positivo y
ahora lo que yo quiero buscar es que
esta expresión que tengo aquí del lado
izquierdo hasta con el espacio sea un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto yo lo puedo
escribir de la forma x más elevado al
cuadrado y si te das cuenta si esto
pasará tendremos que tener x cuadrada x
cuadrado ya la tenemos y después
tendríamos que tener aquí dos veces el
primero por el segundo es decir este de
aquí tendría que ser dos veces el
primero por el segundo 2x y después
tendríamos que tener para finalizar el
segundo elevado al cuadrado por lo tanto
tendremos que aumentarle a cuadrada pero
ojo si aumentamos a cuadrada del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación para que se
mantenga la balanza completamente
equilibrada lo que hay que hacer es
sumarle a cuadrada del otro lado de la
ecuación si nosotros hacemos cualquier
operación o cualquier función de un lado
de la ecuación lo tenemos que hacer
también del otro lado de la ecuación y
bueno si esto fuera cierto me queda que
2a x es igual a 16 x y ya con esto voy a
poder despejar
cuanto vale y si tengo entonces ya puede
trabajar con el cuadrado de am así que
déjenme escribirlo por acá para que
busquemos el valor de amd siempre lo que
esté al lado de la equis lo vamos a
poner igual a 12 x 12 x es igual a 16 x
o si yo paso dividiendo 2x me va a
quedar que a es igual a 16 x entre 2 x
la equis y la x se cancela y 16 entre
2008 y perfecto ya tengo el valor de amd
es decir ya tengo el valor de mi segundo
mono mío en este binomio que voy a
elevar al cuadrado vamos a utilizarlo me
queda x cuadrada más 16 x más el
cuadrado de amd pero el cuadrado de 8 es
aquí hay que poner siempre el cuadrado
del segundo término y también hay que
ponerlo del otro lado de la ecuación
nunca se te olvide ese paso eso es igual
a 57 64 y bueno de este lado de la
ecuación ya estamos formando poco a poco
de aquí acá estamos formando poco a poco
nuestro binomio al cuadrado perfecto y
del otro lado nos queda este término 57
el cual era un término libre que ahora
lo estamos pasando del lado derecho de
la ecuación
y bueno si te das cuenta esto es decir
este lado izquierdo de mi ecuación es
muy parecido a esto que tenemos aquí
abajo o dicho de otra manera esto es lo
mismo que x + ha elevado al cuadrado
pero recuerda en este caso a vale 8 por
lo tanto tenemos x + 8 elevado al
cuadrado del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y del lado derecho tenemos 5764
que es 121 7 4 11 6 y 62 entonces 121
muy bien y ahora que ya tenemos esta
ecuación es mucho más fácil despejar a x
porque porque yo tengo x + 8 elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 121 que te parece si
de aquí pasó este cuadrado del otro lado
de la ecuación cuando yo paso una
potencia del otro lado de la ecuación lo
que realmente estoy haciendo sacar raíz
la cual es la operación contraria a la
potencia por lo tanto aquí me va a
quedar que x más 8 es igual a la raíz de
121 más menos
más o menos la raíz de 121 porque cada
vez que sacamos raíz cuadrada tenemos
una raíz que es positiva y una raíz que
es negativa bueno pero esto ya lo
sabemos entonces me queda que x más 8 es
igual a más menos 11 más menos 11 es la
raíz de 121 y entonces si yo paso el 8
del otro lado me queda que x es igual a
menos 8 más menos 11 ya despeje x y aquí
ya me da dos posibles resultados o que x
sea menos 8 más 11 lo cual me va a dar 3
positivos 8 9 10 11 6 3 positivo mi
primera respuesta es que sea el valor de
x igual a menos 8 más me voy a tomar el
primer signo + 11 lo cual me va a dar 3
y después la segunda respuesta me va a
quedar de tener menos 8 menos 11 es
decir utilizando el segundo signo de esa
igualdad por lo tanto me quedaría que x
en el otro caso va a ser igual a menos
19 menos 8 menos 11 es igual a menos 19
y ya con esto tengo las dos soluciones o
las dos raíces de mi ecuación de segundo
grado con la que empezamos te das cuenta
tal vez en un principio era muy difícil
factorizar pero
ahora ya podemos factorizar de manera
sencilla x cuadrada más 16 x menos 57 es
lo mismo que x 3 por x más 19 porque x
menos 3 igual a 0 me da que x igual a 3
es una raíz y x más 19 igual a 0 me da
que x menos 19 es igual a una raíz y
vamos a ver si funciona 3 x 19 me va a
dar 57 negativo y 19 positivo menos 3 me
da 16 positivo perfecto ya tengo mis dos
raíces de esta ecuación y todo gracias a
que complete el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto te diste cuenta que hay que
hacer lo único que hay que hacer es
primero pasar el término libre del otro
lado y después buscar la forma de
encontrar a amd para que podamos poner
esto con un mínimo el cuadrado perfecto
y después ajustar su cuadrado entonces
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio un poco más
difícil para que nos vaya quedando en
claro cómo se hacen este tipo de
problemas con ecuaciones cuadráticas
completando el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto tomemos la ecuación 6x cuadrada
menos 7 x menos 3 igual a cero si te das
cuenta que ya no está tan sencillo
porque lo primero que podemos ver es que
hay un 6 que está
y por lo tanto factorizar esto no se ve
nada nada sencillo otra cosa que podemos
ver es que no hay factor común por lo
tanto no hay forma de dividir entre nada
6 7 y 3 y que se reduzca todo por lo
tanto qué vamos a hacer en el caso en el
que tenemos a un número multiplicando a
la equis cuadrada cómo podemos resolver
esto completando el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto bueno la técnica es la
siguiente lo primero que hay que hacer
es pasar el 3 del otro lado por lo tanto
me va a quedar 6x cuadrada déjenme
ponerlo aquí 6x cuadrada menos 7x voy a
dejar un espacio para completar el
binomio cuadrado perfecto y esto me
queda igual a 3 lo primero que hay que
hacer es pasar el término libre del otro
lado de mi ecuación claro sin olvidar el
signo contrario hay algunos profesores
que les gusta poner el 3 del otro lado
de la ecuación es decir dejarlo como
estaba y hacerse un poco de bolas cuando
intentan completar el binomio cuadrado
perfecto es un método y también es
bastante bueno a mí en lo personal me
gusta mucho pasar el otro término del
otro lado para que se vea perfectamente
bien que nos ha cuadrado bueno lo que
voy a hacer a continuación
quitar este 6 que me estorba y como lo
voy a quitar pues dividiendo todo entre
6 x cuadrada menos 7 sextos de x esto es
igual a un medio porque 3 el 36 es lo
mismo que un medio y bueno ya que tengo
esto de aquí lo voy a escribir de nuevo
para dejar un poco de espacio porque
ahora voy a completar el binomio al
cuadrado perfecto x cuadrada menos 7
sextos de x aquí voy a dejar un pequeño
espacio y esto va a ser igual a un medio
y ahora bien lo que tengo que encontrar
es quién es mía cuadrada es decir quién
es mi segundo término elevado al
cuadrado y para esto voy a recordar la
fórmula del binomio al cuadrado perfecto
es muy importante que todas recuerdes
porque lo que vamos a buscar es que este
término de aquí este que tengo aquí sea
dos veces
o dicho de otra manera dividiendo este
término entre dos voy a sacar a pero
bueno siempre es muy importante que
recuerde esta fórmula tan x masa elevado
al cuadrado es cuadrado del primero más
dos veces el primero por el segundo más
cuadrado del segundo es justo en esto en
lo que me estoy basando para completar
el binomio cuadrado perfecto por lo
tanto vamos a sacarle la mitad a menos 7
sextos por qué darte cuenta que si yo
saco la mitad de menos 7 sextos
el valor de amd por lo tanto vamos a
hacer una igualdad a va a ser igual a
menos 7 sextos entre 2 que es lo mismo
que menos 7 sextos entre 2 entre 1 y
usando la ley del sandwich me sale que a
es igual a menos 7 entre 12 es decir la
mitad de este coeficiente que yo tengo
aquí y bueno si ya tengo que a es igual
a menos 7 entre 12 entonces su cuadrado
va a ser cuadrado del de arriba que me
da 49 y cuadrado del de abajo que me da
144 es decir que menos 7 entre 12
elevado al cuadrado me da 49 entre 144 y
recuerda que lo que yo hago de un lado
de la ecuación lo tengo que hacer
también del otro lado de la ecuación y
bueno todo esto que tengo aquí justo
pues lo construimos es un binomio
cuadrado perfecto es decir que x
cuadrada menos 7 sextos de x más 49 en
344 es el binomio al cuadrado perfecto
ya sabemos que vale menos 7 entre 12 y
entonces esto de aquí me va a quedar
como x menos 7 entre 12 elevado al
cuadrado así que déjame ponerlo
esto es x menos 7 doceavos menos 72 ya
vos justo aquí es donde utilizó la
información que obtuve al saque
el valor de a y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado y bueno esto va a ser igual a
la otra parte de la ecuación la otra
parte de la ecuación mi lado derecho me
queda un medio más 49 entre 144 así que
voy a sacar el mínimo común múltiplo que
es 144 la mitad de 144 72 y después de
sumo 49 y 72 unos 49 m 221 dividido
entre 144 y bueno ya tengo una ecuación
en la cual puede despejar a equis tengo
x menos 7 medios al cuadrado es igual a
121 entre 144 así que saquemos la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados de la ecuación
déjame hacer un poco de espacio para que
me quede el final de esta ecuación y me
queda que x menos 7 doceavos va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 121 entre
144 positiva y negativa es decir más
menos 11 entre 12 la raíz cuadrada de
121 son c la raíz cuadrada de 144 es 12
y bueno ya con esta igualdad que tenemos
aquí podemos despejar a x x es igual a 7
entre 12 lo pasé con signo positivo más
menos 11 entre 12 y entonces que me
queda que x
7 - 11 / 12 o dicho de otra manera ya
encuentre las dos raíces de esta
ecuación 7 11 entre 12 es lo mismo que
18 entre 12 que es lo mismo que 9 entre
6 que es lo mismo que tres medios es la
primera raíz y la segunda raíz me queda
7 menos 11 entre 12 lo cual no queda
menos 412 abós que es menos un tercio y
ya lo tenemos ya tenemos las soluciones
de la ecuación 6x cuadrada menos 7 x
menos 3 igual a 0 y si tú quisieras de
pura casualidad demostrar la fórmula
general lo único que hay que hacer es
poner aquí a b y c y utilizar el mismo
procedimiento que acabamos de ver y así
llegarías a la solución que nos da la
fórmula general de ecuaciones de segundo
grado así que eso es todo por este vídeo
y espero que en los vídeos próximos
pueda demostrar que la fórmula general
de ecuaciones de segundo grado
utilizando este procedimiento